[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAREN: So I'm really excited
to have Lauren Leader Chivee
and Alysia Reiner here
to talk to us today
about diversity and diversity
in all aspects of media
and industry.
And this is exciting
for me, because Lauren
used to be my boss in my
old job before Google.
I know we don't talk
about life before Google,
but I did have a
job before that.
And she was my boss, and
so it's super exciting
to have her here to talk
about this book, which
has been something that has
been in discussion for a while.
So with that, I'm going to
welcome Lauren Leader Chivee
up.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here,
and hi to everyone in
other Google offices
outside of New York.
I do really appreciate
that you're here,
and it feels like a
particularly important time
to be having this conversation.
I started working on the
book, "Crossing the Thinnest
Line," well over a year ago.
And when I thought of
started, I did have some sense
that with the election we might
have a somewhat contentious
election cycle.
You could sense that there was
stuff brewing in the country,
but I had no idea that
we would be where we are.
I can't say that it's
the happiest place.
It's been incredibly
painful to watch.
I think it's been incredibly
painful for a lot of Americans
to watch.
And in the middle
of the cold cycle,
as things were
beginning to ratchet up,
in terms of the
noise in the country
about the election, but
then also the emergence
of the Black Lives
Matter movement
over the last few
years, the continuing
intensity around conflicts
around race and gender
and the breakdown in a way
of the national conversation,
I sat down to try to
write a book about how
we can do better.
And I will say that having
a book like that come out
right now is actually
really challenging.
Because it's not what
people want to talk about.
When you turn on
the news, and I'm
sure if you had any
channel on last night,
you saw the kind of
intensity and conflict
that is just dominating every
minute of the news cycle.
And there's been very little
conversation about the role
that we all can play
in doing better.
So I'm going to
back up for a second
and just give you a little
bit about me and about why
I wrote the book.
Because I do think it's
important, especially
because I am the white
privileged woman that I
am, standing up here to talk
to a very diverse set of Google
employees and out
there in the world
talking to a very diverse
country about this topic.
And so I do think and I
felt in writing the book
that I needed to say a
little bit about who I am
and how I got here.
So I grew up in Washington DC.
And Washington DC
has always been
and remains and one of the most
diverse cities in the nation.
In the 1980s, when I was
growing up, it was over 90%
African-American.
And my experience
of that childhood
was-- I'm realizing
now and I've come
to realize-- pretty unique.
Because most American
don't grow up
in communities that are anywhere
near as diverse as the one
that I grew up in.
Now, my immediate neighborhood,
the block where my house was,
was actually almost
entirely white.
And Washington is
actually segregated
in these very strange ways.
It's segregated by
race but it's also
even segregated by
political party.
We didn't have any
Republicans on our block.
I mean, it was like
all Peace Corps,
ex-Peace Peace Corps volunteers.
So not the most of
our neighborhoods.
But the city itself
was so diverse
that all my schools
were incredibly diverse.
I always had 30% to
40% of my classmates,
from kindergarten all the
way through high school,
and I write a lot about
high school in the book,
were at leaves 30% to
40% diverse in some way,
because this city is
also the home of all
of the embassies for
the United States.
And so there our families from
every corner of the world.
In kindergarten, I probably had
nine different nationalities
represented.
And that left a
big impact on me.
And I also had a lot of
African-American friends
with a child.
The thing that I came
to learn, though,
and I really was, I
think like many kids,
not especially conscious of
the thing that divided us
as a child, but I was very lucky
because two things happened.
One is that, in about
the seventh grade,
and I write a lot about
this in the book--
in the seventh grade, I
had this really painful
personal experience,
which is that I was--
and this is a very
seventh grade thing,
to put it in context,
because we're all
a little emotional
and a little awkward
and sensitive in
the seventh grade.
But in the seventh grade, I went
to this very exclusive girls'
school, outside of DC, in
suburban Potomac, Maryland,
which was very conservative,
entirely white.
By the way, I stayed at
this school only two years,
partly because of this.
And in the seventh grade,
someone in my class
had a birthday party,
and I was the only one
in the class not invited.
And it turns out that the
reason that I wasn't invited
was because the party was being
held at the Chevy Chase Country
Club, which in 1988, did
not have a single minority
or Jewish member.
Because we were Jewish,
I was not invited.
My mom, when she explained to
me why I hadn't been invited,
used it as an opportunity
to recount to me
all the discrimination that
American Jews have faced.
And it turns out that
my own grandfather
had changed his
name in the 1950s ad
from Goldberg to Gilbert,
because in most of America,
he couldn't get a hotel room
with the last name Goldberg.
It's a piece of American
history that most of us
don't even think about anymore.
But it was true.
Was it the biggest,
most transformational
personal experience in my life?
Of course not.
Does it compare in any way
to the kind of exclusion
and challenges that visible
minorities in this country
face?
Of course not.
But something happened for me
at that point in my life, which
is that I was humiliated,
and angry, and hurt,
and I could not stand
the injustice of it.
It made me crazy.
So to fast forward, I
was lucky enough to go.
I left.
I got out of that school
as soon as I could,
and I went to a
school in Washington
called Georgetown
Day School, which
was actually built to
be the first integrated
school in Washington.
It was established in
the 1940s, at the time
when DC was a highly segregated
city, which many people don't
know the history of
Washington and how
segregated it really was.
But it was in many
ways a microcosm
of the bias that was
happening in the nation.
But GDS was set up as this
place for diverse communities
in Washington to get educated.
And so when I got there,
it also turned out
to be a place where
people talked about race
and difference all the time.
And the school did
something really amazing,
which is that in my
freshman year, when
a bunch of African-American
senior girls
were feeling angry
and like second class
citizens in the school, because
they felt they were not being
treated fairly by some of the
white students, the school,
to their credit, suspended
classes for three days
in my freshman year
of high school,
and brought in Juan Williams,
who had not long before written
the book "Eyes on the Prize,"
to facilitate a summit on race
for a bunch of high school kids.
It was life altering.
But the thing about
that, and the reason
why I tell that story,
is that part of what
made me able to relate to and
understand, or at least try
to understand, the pain that
these amazing African-American
girls, who were seniors at
the time, who I worshiped
and thought were the coolest
girls in the whole world,
part of why I cried
for them was because I
had had some experience
of being an outsider,
that that experience of having
been excluded for something
I couldn't control,
that I was Jewish,
helped me understand something
different about them.
So fast forward.
Because I actually happen
to think-- first of all,
I've come to realize
how lucky I am that I
had any of those experiences.
Because it has created--
and I am in no way
left biased than anyone
else in the country.
I am in no way-- I
don't understand it
in any greater detail
than anybody else,
but it has made me want to try.
And it's made me commit a big
part of my career to trying
to create the context
and the environment
and the opportunities
for us all to do better.
And that's what I committed
to when writing this book--
could we find a
way to do better?
Well, one thing that I think
is fundamental to that,
and you can look at what's
happened in North Carolina
or in Oklahoma or any
of the other places
around the country now,
where there are now
these endless streams of
hashtag that in a couple
letters try to capture the pain
and the complexity of what's
happening in the
country right now.
We need desperately
for more Americans,
and I absolutely believe
that we especially need
more white Americans, to have
a deeper appreciation for,
empathy for, and understanding
of the experiences that
non-majority-- although
even that is changing,
so we'll talk about
that in a minute--
how all Americans are
experiencing our country.
If we cannot get to a
deeper level of empathy
and understanding, we are doomed
to continue to repeat these
same cycles over and over again.
I do a lot of media, and I've
been spending a lot of time
on Fox News.
I've become the progressive
punching bag on Fox News.
They love having me as often
as I'll come that day so they
can scream and yell at me.
But I was invited to speak
after one of the major incidents
a few months ago.
I can't even remember.
Dallas, after Dallas.
There have been so many
the year I lose track.
But after the Dallas
shooting, I was
invited on Megyn
Kelly's show to be part
of this discussion on race.
And I was kind of
optimistic about it.
Because I thought, "all right.
They're doing it.
It's going to be
nationally televised.
That's promising."
And I get to the green
room and it's actually
a very diverse room.
And I'm kind of like,
"hm, well done, Fox News.
I'm impressed with who
you've pulled into this room
to have this conversation."
And we go in, and we
sit down in the chairs
before the cameras come on.
And the producer
says, "we really need
a thoughtful and meaningful
conversation about this.
This is a time when the
country is in crisis.
We want all of you
to bring your best.
Please don't scream.
People will change the channel.
It's not good for
ratings, but it's also not
good for this conversation."
So I'm feeling great.
I'm like, "yeah,
we're going to have
this meaningful conversation.
Yay, Fox News."
I'm sure you can guess that
it didn't quite go that way.
So it opened with one guest who
started with the following--
"Black Lives Matter is
more racist than the KKK."
That was the opener.
So you can imagine where
it went from there.
By the way, that was an
African-American person
who said that.
So I'm not really sure
where they found it.
Anyway, and then the
next conversation
was somebody else who
said, "we should just
disband the entire
American police force.
We don't need to
believe anymore."
So very productive
rational conversation
that was happening.
And then in between, it
was just people literally
screaming at the
top of their lungs,
as loud as they possibly could.
And in between, and
this is the part
that I think that is
so heartbreaking to me,
in between, Megyn Kelly, who
I really do respect and think
is an incredibly smart
and gifted person,
Megyn Kelly was thrilled.
And at the commercial break,
she encouraged us to keep at it.
Because it makes
for great ratings.
So think about that.
Is that really where we
want to be as a country?
So in the context
of all of this,
part of what I try to do in
"Crossing the Thinnest Line"
is paint a picture of
not just what's at stake.
And what's at stake is enormous.
We have a lot at
stake economically.
We certainly have a
lot at stake socially.
It is critically important
to the future of our country
that we do better in
terms of inclusion
and this overall approach
that we take to the fact
that our nation will, in
less than a generation,
be a minority majority nation.
We are seeing the
sort of anxiety
and the backlash
again that really come
to the fore in this election.
I think that is
actually probably
one of the most salient pieces
of what's happening today
is this discomfort that many,
especially white Americans have
with the changing
face of our nation.
I don't think you
can deny that that
is a significant
undercurrent here.
But what it takes to
do better, I think,
and we're going to talk
about one small piece of it
today, the media and
Hollywood piece of it, which
might seem like
the least important
but actually has a role to play.
In the book, I try to make
the case that it's actually
a whole bunch of things.
It's not just about
how much better
do we do on diversity
at a company like Google
or at any American company,
which is mostly where we're
talking about diversity today.
We are mostly talking about
it in the corporate context,
right?
How to get more women
and people of color
to go into STEM, how our
businesses can do better,
how to have more women
and people of color
on corporate boards
and in the C-Suite.
That matters, but there's
a whole panoply of factors.
One of them is what's
happening in education
and I talked about my
own formative experience.
Unfortunately, the
trends in the country
are not going in the right way.
If you look at
the charts of what
happened to school
integration since Brown
vs. Board of education,
it is a bell curve,
and the trend of reversing.
So American public schools
are now becoming less diverse.
And it is actually
the private schools,
in many ways, so for the
folks who can afford it,
who get to send their
kids to private schools.
The private schools
are working overtime
to try to make sure
they're diverse.
But our public school
system is becoming
more segregated than ever.
And I talk a lot about
that in the book.
So we're maybe preparing
the next generation
to potentially reverse
some of the gains that
have been made with
Gen Y and Gen Z
and some of the
younger Americans.
I don't know.
It's a question.
We have a challenge
around mass incarceration,
which you absolutely cannot
separate from the larger
question of how are we doing
on diversity in this country.
We are locking up
an entire generation
of minority Americans.
And if we don't
address that and see
that as part of the overall
picture of diversity
in the country, we are missing
a very important and significant
piece.
Obviously, the business
piece is important.
Immigration continues to be,
especially in this election
cycle, a really intense
topic of dispute and debate.
But of course--
and I know you all
know this in a company
like Google-- immigrants
to the country, including, by
the way, those who are here
who are undocumented,
contribute enormously
to the American economy.
Undocumented
immigrants pay billions
of dollars in taxes
every year, which
is an extraordinary piece
of the picture which
doesn't get much attention.
And then what I want to
invite Alysia to talk about
with me in a minute is this
entertainment and media piece,
which seems silly in the
context of talking about some
of the big issues we have
around criminal justice
reform and education
and immigration, right?
But part of what I argue in
the book is but what we see
and what we see
intensely all the time
now because of the boundaryless
sources of information
that come at us, what we see
in the media, in Hollywood,
on television, maybe
matters more than ever.
And the challenge
is that we have not
made the kind of
progress in ensuring
that the images and the
stories that we see actually
represent our country.
So I'm going to invite up Alysia
Reiner, my dear friend, who
I'll also introduce to
come up and join me.
We'll have a bit
of a conversation.
We really want to encourage
you to participate in this.
This is not just about me.
And fundamentally for us to
make progress as a country,
it takes a lot of conversation.
And then the last
thing I'll just
say about this is
that I do think--
and I write a lot about
this in the book-- I do
believe that white America has
an outsized responsibility.
And white male America
in many instances
has an outsized responsibility
in solving these issues
and in finding a
way to understand.
The one point I managed to make
on Megyn Kelly's crazy show
that day is that, in the end,
it doesn't matter whether or not
I can understand in a
personal or a deep way
the experience of what
it's like to drive around
the country as an
African-American.
I will never understand that.
I'm a white person.
I can never fully appreciate
what that feels like.
But I have a responsibility,
and I believe we all
do, that if any American, if any
American feels that they do not
have full access to
the American dream,
or that they are in any way
have less than the full rights
and privileges and equality
of all other American,
then we all have
a responsibility
to try to make it better,
whether we agree with it
or relate to it or not.
And so all the
conversations we're
having today about "I
believe it's racist,"
"I don't believe it's racist,"
"I think the cops are racist,"
"I don't think the cops are
racist,"-- it doesn't matter.
None of it matters.
Because if any Americans
feel-- if any American feel
that our country is
not a full meritocracy,
is not fully accessible, that
the American dream is not
accessible to all Americans,
then we all have work to do.
So with that, I want to
invite up Alysia Reiner,
the amazing and talented.
I know many of you know her.
I'm very lucky that Alysia and
I have been very dear friends
for a long time.
We're actually neighbors.
We both live in Harlem and have
lived there for a long time.
Our little girls
are the same age.
And Alysia doesn't meed
a ton of introduction.
I'm sure you have seen her
on the amazing show "Orange
is the New Black,"
which is one of the few
shows out there--
it's certainly one
of the only shows with an
all female cast or a majority
female cast, one
of the few shows
that also has really focused
on the mass incarceration issue
as one of the
themes of the show.
Alysia, along with many of the
cast members and the writers
have also put a lot of
time into calling attention
to criminal justice reform and
mass incarceration of women,
which is important.
And her new movie,
"Equity," which
she was here at Google when?
Like a month ago?
Yeah, a month ago to talk about.
It's the first all-female driven
movie, a Wall Street film,
that was written by,
directed by, and starred in
by-- that's not really
a sentence-- all women.
And I've been talking
with her about that movie
for a very long time.
So please join me in
welcoming Alysia Reiner.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
ALYSIA REINER: Hi.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: How are you?
ALYSIA REINER: I'm good.
Am I on.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
I think she's on.
Is she on?
She's not on.
Are we on the screen?
Can they see us in California?
California, Houston,
are you there?
So I started to say
that in many ways
it's hard to think of
Hollywood, or movies, or TV,
which is fun and fluffy, right?
Sexy and fun and fluffy,
it's hard to think about that
as having an important role
to play in the context of all
the rest of this.
But I know that I
often talk about it
and I say-- I tell this story in
the book that when I was a kid,
one of the most influential
women that I saw on television
was Wonder Woman.
And Wonder Woman
was at her height
of power in my early childhood.
Lynda Carter lived
in Washington.
And that was also a
big thing, and she
lived in my
neighborhood and I used
to ride my bike past
her house, always
trying to get a glimpse
of her because I
was so obsessed with her.
I never saw her.
But Wonder Woman kicked ass.
I mean, she was an
absolute feminist icon.
And for me, it made
a big difference.
But it does feel
like in some ways--
and I think the
numbers bear this out,
and I know you know them really
well-- this sort of early '80s,
late '70s, early '80s, in
many ways was a high point.
We haven't really seen
a substantial increase
in women role models in the
movies and on TV since then.
ALYSIA REINER: I am here
later today for the Gina Davis
Symposium, in which
we'll talk about
not only the actual
statistics but perhaps
a piece of technology that
Google is involved with
to look at these statistics.
And I just want to roll
it back for a second
and say thank you for
everything that you've said.
Also as a very
privileged white woman,
I grew up thinking I
was outrageously lucky.
And I was teased mercilessly.
We now call it bullying.
But I was the fat kid
and teased mercilessly.
And there were this
interesting dichotomy of "oh,
I feel like the outsider.
I feel like crap."
But I went to a very privileged
white fairly diverse school,
but was made aware
because it was a very--
it was ethical
culture which makes
you very aware of your
privilege and aware of the world
around you.
And we learned ethics
in first grade.
And I felt very "like how dare
I feel anything but lucky."
That's pretty much
how I grew up and felt
a similar responsibility to
make change for others, not
for myself.
So I think coming to a
place where I was really
looking at the statistics
about women in the media
took me a long time, because
I had this "how dare I"
mentality.
And then I did become
aware of the statistics.
And a lot of it had to do
with becoming a mother for me.
Because what you said about
"if you see it, you can be it,"
I became the mother of
a girl, of a daughter,
and I wanted her to
see certain things.
And I then did some research.
And Stacey Smith does
some amazing research.
The Gina Davis Institute
does some amazing research.
And what I found out is
77% of the people you
see in all of media, which
includes film, television,
cartoons-- everything,
75% are male.
So when you're looking
at that as a human being,
as a female human being, you
feel like a massive minority.
As I explained it to my--
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
Which is ridiculous.
ALYSIA REINER: Because it's not.
And as a male, you feel
like you own the world.
And that is something that
we're seeing every day.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: By the way,
one of the most
interesting things
that I heard someone say
to me about the movie
"Equity," which I encourage
you to all go see.
First buy my book.
Then go see "Equity."
Sorry, I get to do that.
ALYSIA REINER: Please.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: Her movie's
been out for a little while.
Mine just came out this week.
My book just came out this week.
But one of the most
interesting things
that I heard somebody say
after seeing "Equity,"
was a friend of mine
went with her husband--
and if you've not
seen the movie,
the female characters
really drive the movie.
And it is the story of
women, a very important story
of women on Wall Street.
It's also a thriller.
It's not overtly about
women in a traditional way,
but it is driven by women.
And one of the things that
my friend's husband said
to her was "the male
characters are so one
dimensional and thinly drawn."
And she's like--
ALYSIA REINER:
Welcome to our world.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
Yeah, welcome to our world.
Because if you look at
movies like "Wall Street"
or any of these movies,
I mean, I think,
when I watched it the first
time, I started laughing.
Because of course
the first time you
see a woman in "The
Wolf of Wall Street"
is Margot Robbie naked
in the bubble bath.
And you're like,
"seriously, guys?
Really?"
And then the next one is the
sniveling, insecure secretary.
Anyway, you get the point.
But the point is that one
of the things that I thought
was so interesting is
this week with the Emmys
and of course after the Oscars
so White controversy last year,
which is, by the way, not over.
So stay tuned for February.
We'll see if there's any
significant improvements.
It's unlikely.
But one thing that's
super interesting
is that the Emmys this
year were so focused.
There was much
attention on diversity,
shows like
"Transparent" and others
that got a lot of attention.
So you might conclude
that TV is doing
pretty well, that there's
Shondaland and all the things,
right?
ALYSIA REINER: It's
disturbing when
there is information like that.
Yeah, that makes us feel
like "oh, we're doing great,"
because statistically
speaking, we're not.
And statistically
speaking, 8% of directors
are women, similar
to 8% of female CEOs.
And we do have, I think,
1% or 2% cinematographers.
We do have that 77%
gap, even in the extras
you see in the background,
in bizonker crowd scenes.
So how do we change that?
And "Equity" was a
big piece of that.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
So I think part of it
is too-- you talked
about your daughter
and I haven't talked
about my kids,
but it is an important
piece of the puzzle which
I didn't mention, which is
that both my daughters are
African-American.
And so when I think about what
I want for them, obviously,
at her age, I'm glad we have
"Doc McStuffins," which,
by the way, just got
cancelled, if you didn't know.
Tragic loss in Disneyland, "Doc
McStuffins" has been cancelled.
My daughter's devastated.
She's seen every episode
at least 100 times.
But that question of what
an impact it really makes.
And I talk a little
bit in the book
about the impact
of "The Cosby Show"
and how groundbreaking that
was for so many Americans.
And I think now in some
ways "Master of None"
is breaking that territory
for Asian-Americans.
We've seen so few
Asian-Americans ever
in his speech at
the Emmys, right?
ALYSIA REINER:
"Fresh off the Boat."
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
"Fresh off of the Boat."
I mean, this is
the biggest deal.
I mean, these are huge
segments of American society,
and yet we barely see them.
So Alysia, what's the problem?
Given that there's a good
economic case, certainly
in Hollywood, the movies and
the shows that do actually
reflect the country
do really well.
I mean, you look at how "Frozen"
became the highest grossing
animated film of all time.
So why is it so
hard to make change
and to see stories in Hollywood
that look like America?
ALYSIA REINER: In
my experience, it's
a couple of different things.
One is our unconscious bias.
I think there are
so many parts of us
that we are simply not aware of.
And you were talking earlier
about the overresponsibility
of the white male, and I
really believe that to be true.
Because--
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
Because they're in power.
ALYSIA REINER: A, they
are in power, and B,
I feel like there are so
many systems in place that
are habit.
We all have our habits.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Yeah.
ALYSIA REINER: And some of
them are good and some of them
are bad.
Hiring our friends is a big
habit a lot of people have.
Hiring people that
look like you,
that feel like you, that
you're comfortable with,
is just a truth that
most of the world does.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
I mean, I always make
the joke that like Karen's
my key demographic, right?
Nice Jewish girls from a
similar background to me.
I totally was biased
in my hiring of Karen.
ALYSIA REINER: And I'm going
to talk about it for myself.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: We all do it.
We all do it.
ALYSIA REINER: I was at
a screening of "Equity."
I did a Q&A. And this
girl who looked just
like one of the
girls I grew up with,
looked like in Upper West
Side girl, came up to me
and started talking to me.
And her daughter
goes to Bank Street.
My daughter goes to Bank Street.
And all of a sudden,
we're friends.
And I don't know if that would
have happened if it was a man.
Probably not, first of
all because I'm married.
And I only say that
because if I was a man
and a woman came up to
me, that's not cool.
So I'm not going
to hire that woman,
or I'm not going to maybe
be friends with that women,
because what is my
wife going to think?
And these are these
unconscious biases,
these stereotypes that we
aren't aware of sometimes,
that we have to make
ourselves aware of.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: I mean,
I'm controversial on this,
though, because I will say
that I don't actually subscribe
to it always being unconscious.
And it actually makes
me a little crazy,
because I often feel like
the constant conversation
about unconscious bias sometimes
lets people off the hook.
Like, "oh, I just
wasn't conscious.
No, no.
It doesn't work that way.
You don't get to be unconscious.
By the way, I think sometimes
it is absolutely blatantly
conscious.
Some of the biases that we are
seeing in this election cycle,
you can't tell me that people
aren't conscious of the fact
that we don't ask men
to smile when they're
running for president, and yet
we ask women to smile, right?
So I get really
fired up about this.
One thing i just wanted to
share is that part of why I--
and this is not to be a
pain-in-the-ass about it,
but I do think it's
not an excuse anymore.
Unconscious bias doesn't
get to be an excuse forever.
"Oh, I wasn't conscious,
and so I just-- oops.
My bad."
We have to got beyond
that as a country.
We have to do better than that.
And one of the reasons why
I called the book "Crossing
the Thinnest Line,"
and I did want
to briefly tell this story.
Alysia knows the story,
but I'll tell it briefly.
It's that I have these
two fabulous colleagues,
these lovely guys who
work with me in Boston.
And they are these central
casting, white, Bostonian,
Catholic guys.
And you would not
look at them and think
that they were-- I made
a lot of assumptions
about them, as we always do
about everyone that we meet.
Well, it turns out that my
colleague, Brian and Shawn,
are part of the incredible
prison ministry in Boston.
And they, along with a
bunch of other mostly white
male executives from a
bunch of awesome companies,
are part of a parish that
goes into largely minority--
because that is who the
prison population is--
maximum security prisons
around the Boston area
and do these amazing of
collaborative ministries.
And the thing that Bryan
said to me about it
is why I titled the
book the way I did.
And he blew me away
when he said this.
He said after visiting
these prisons--
and he was terrified to do it.
He thought "what am I going to
have to say to these people?
What do I have in
common with them?"
After the first
visit, he walked out
and said, "The line
between us is so very thin.
If I had made one different
decision in my life,
I might be where they are.
If they had made one
different decision
or had one different
opportunity in their lives,
they might be where I am."
And I was so blown away that
he thought of that as a thin,
that he actually
saw there being so
little difference between them.
And I thought,
"that's what we need.
That's what we need
in the country,
is we need more people to
see these lines as thin."
And so I want to open
it up, because I think
we should have a conversation.
But Hollywood does have
this amazing ability
through storytelling
to help people
relate to other human beings
they might not otherwise
relate to.
So what are you seeing?
What are your signs of hope?
What do you see changing people?
What do you think is the
possibility for that?
Are we moving?
The pace is glacial, but are
you optimistic, pessimistic?
ALYSIA REINER: I'm
very optimistic.
I think I am by
nature an optimist.
And when you were talking about
how we make unconscious bias
and that lets
people off the hook,
I believe that we're good.
I was at an event
yesterday, and they
were talking about Einstein.
He had this core
question-- do you believe
the world is good or not?
Do you believe that
we're all trying
to make it better or not?
And that really is a core
question, because if you do
believe in the good, then
you act from the good.
And I really believe in good.
So I believe that we can only
teach with love and compassion
and empathy and compassion.
And so, yes, I believe we
are changing for the good.
I really do.
I think it takes a
lot of conversations
like this and a lot of
talking about the things that
are really painful
and uncomfortable
and making art about it.
And I became an
artist because I felt
like that was the leave
where I could reach the most
people with truths that they're
sometimes afraid to talk about
in other areas.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: Have you seen
people changed through shows
like "Orange is the New Black?"
I know you've had lots
of people come up to you
and say things to you about it.
ALYSIA REINER: Absolutely.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: So
would anyone stand out?
What do you think
has been the change
that a show like
"Orange" had made?
ALYSIA REINER: I think it's
simply that thinnest line.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: People
relating to those women.
ALYSIA REINER: And feeling
like that could be me.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: Well, that's
what the show does
so well, right?
It's the stories of that
Piper's story too, right?
ALYSIA REINER: And it's true.
And how do we tell stories
that create more compassion?
The first movie that
I made as a producer
was a short about
grief and loss.
I had lost my dad really
suddenly to cancer.
He was 55.
And I felt like a pariah.
Everyone was afraid to talk
to me because they were
so afraid to talk about death.
And they didn't know
how to talk about it,
so they just wouldn't.
And so I made this movie, and I
worked with 10 grief counselors
and social workers, and we
created basically some art
therapy with all the
different phases of grieving.
And we created a
discussion guide
and a journal that
went with it as a way
to help people process.
And I do believe deeply in
this healing power of art
or I wouldn't be here.
I think it's hard
in moments like this
and in what's going
on in the world,
because you almost can't
make the art fast enough
to really make impact.
So then I think for me,
in a moment like this,
especially as a white,
privileged woman,
how do I make things happen?
That's the biggest
question I turn over
to you in these moments.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: I want
to open it up to conversation.
I mentioned my kids,
one of the things
that I learned, having worked
on diversity for years,
one of the things I learned
when researching the book
is how often minority Americans
talk to their children
about race and how rarely
white Americans do.
So I had a personal experience
of this, which I really
had to face, which is that
when my daughter, Stella,
who's now seven, came home from
preschool when she was three,
she came home one day and
said, "Mama, I'm brown,"
and wanted to talk about
the fact that she was brown
and some of the other
kids in her class
weren't, and it wasn't probably
as diverse as a preschool
as I would have
liked for her, but it
was the one that we picked.
And if she wanted
to talk about it.
And my immediate, visceral-- so
here was my unconscious thing,
thinking I'm so
progressive about it--
my immediate,
visceral reaction was
I wanted to change the subject.
And I thought, well, why am I
trying to change the subject?
It's just an objective truth.
What am I going to do?
Tell her you're not?
That's ridiculous.
I have to be able
to talk about this.
And so I had to
take a deep breath
and face my own discomfort.
I tell this story because when
I was researching the book,
one of the things
that I learned is
that there's been
all this psychology
and psychological
research that's
been done about conversations
around race with children.
And it turns out-- and
so much of white America,
we want to be colorblind, right?
We want to see
everyone as the same.
And that is a big theme in
this election, by the way.
If you watch five minutes
of conservative news,
if you watch Fox
for five minutes,
you will hear guest
after guest after guest
challenge the assumption that
there is racism in the country,
challenge the
assumption that any
of the big issues that
we're facing are about race.
And you've got to
listen to that,
because it's actually
a very significant part
of the American perspective.
And if we deny it, we're
missing a whole thing.
But here's the thing about it.
So even the most
well-intentioned
among us, who think
that by not talking
about race with our kids we
are raving colorblind children.
Well, it turns out that,
psychologically, it
has the opposite effect, that
in the absence of conversation,
in the absence of information,
our children actually
draw a negative conclusion.
The very thing that so many
white Americans do to try to be
good citizens-- "we don't
need to talk about that,
because we're all the same"--
it's exactly the wrong choice.
Because it's
actually reinforcing.
Our kids assume that when
we're not talking about it,
it's because there's
something wrong or bad
that we're uncomfortable with.
ALYSIA REINER: I want
to piggyback on that.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
And then in the media,
we're not talking
about it either.
So where are they
going to get it?
ALYSIA REINER: Correct.
And I feel like it's so much
better and easier with kids,
because they're
so much more open.
When you guys have
workshops on diversity,
it feels a little
forced sometimes.
And I think with kids, at our
school, sincec first grade,
she's had racial justice
and advocacy classes,
in the first grade.
And my favorite part
is they talk regularly.
There are four different
kinds-- not kinds of people.
They would hate me saying that.
There are four
different categories
of human in anything situation.
So in any situation where
there is a conflict,
there's the mistake-maker,
the target, the bystander,
and the ally.
What I love about
that breakdown is
that the mistake-maker
and the bystander
are almost neck and neck as
mistake-makers, that if you
are a bystander, that's not OK.
And I love that my daughter
goes to a school that
teaches it is not OK
to be a bystander,
that it is your
job to be an ally.
That is your job in life.
And that's that
unconscious bias.
How do we untrain ourselves and
how do we train our children?
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
So I want to open it up
to a conversation in the room.
There's lots of better
perspectives than ours.
AUDIENCE: Hi, wanted
talk about something
you mentioned earlier, when
you mentioned the Emmys
and their push for diversity.
So at the Emmys,
Jeffrey Tambor, he
won an award for "Transparent."
And in his speech, he
mentioned how important
it was to let transwomen
actually be on TV
and control their stories.
But the obvious irony of that is
that Jeffrey Tambor is himself
a cis-man playing a transwoman.
And so my question
is, how can you
make sure people in
positions of power
like that actually
do vacate their spot
and actually do make room
for people who need it?
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: That's great.
I love that question.
What do you think?
ALYSIA REINER: I think they've
got to say no, first of all.
Yeah, I think a big
piece of it is--
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: By the way,
also white actresses
playing minority characters
that they have no
business of doing.
"Aloha," anyone?
There's a long list of those,
which I talk about in the book.
They should never have said
yes to this part, right?
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah.
So I want to start by saying
one of my favorite parts
is that Jeffrey Tambor
called himself out on it.
That takes a lot of balls.
You're winning an award
and you're like, "dude,
this is not OK."
And I think creating
art that talks about--
like I love Jill Soloway
so much, because she
told her story.
She didn't look for
the story that she
thought would make the
most money or whatever.
She told the story
that needed to be
told in her heart and the story
that she was afraid to tell,
the story she was probably
most afraid to tell,
because as she's now put
out, it's her family's story.
And I think that's
what we all have to do.
She also said "topple
the patriachy."
I don't know how to do that.
I've thought about it a lot.
What I know how to do is make
my art and make my own choices.
When I made my movie, I
said from the beginning,
before we even
hired the writer, "I
want to play a woman
married to a woman married
to a woman of color."
Because if I'm
making this movie,
I want to create an extra
role for a diverse woman,
a woman from the LGBT
community, and a woman.
So I hit those three checks.
Now, I did hire an actual
African-American woman.
It's tricky, then, to
go, "oh, is it OK for me
to ask people are you gay?"
That's actually discrimination.
when I am casting
that role, I'm not
allowed to ask
that question, just
like I'm not allowed
to ask their age,
even though there's incredible
racism and ageism and so
many isms in Hollywood.
So there's a lot tricky
navigating there.
Is it OK?
Here I was an,
actress and producer,
trying to create
more roles for women,
women of color, LGBT women.
Was it wrong for me to play it?
Because I played a lesbian?
Should I have hired someone
else to play my own role?
I don't know.
I've never thought
about it that way.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Yeah.
And that is, I
think, in some ways
a gray-- I don't know if
other people may disagree.
There are gray areas on these
issues, but I do think, to me,
there's no gray area,
no gray area whatsoever
when we are hiring white actors
to play minority characters.
It's just unacceptable.
This happened in the
"Star Trek" movies.
It happened in
the movie "Aloha."
We continue to do this.
It's absolutely unacceptable.
ALYSIA REINER: And I will
say, I just did "23 and Me,"
so I know exactly what
I am so that I make
sure not to lie about that.
Do you know what I mean?
I did that exactly
for that reason.
Because everyone's
like, "are you Italian?
Are you Russian?
What are you?
Are you Armenian?"
And my grandparents
tell me one thing.
And I've played
Armenians, and I believe
I am, in fact, Armenian.
But I was often
told I was Egyptian,
and I'm doing "23 and Me"
to find out if I really am.
LAUREN LEADER
CHIVEE: Let me know.
ALYSIA REINER: OK.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have lived
in Oakland, California,
for the past several years,
raised both my kids in Oakland.
We are the most progressive
humans on the earth.
And so I find I just get
so pissed at all my friends
who are less progressive.
I have some friends that live
in the central part of the state
of California,
places like Arizona,
and I just-- I
watch them evolve.
And you said the
pace is glacial.
And it is glacial.
When they finally get
it, it's like-- I mean,
I'm super optimistic.
Don't get me wrong.
But these people, when
they are so slow to evolve,
it makes me crazy.
How you have patience?
And one other thing.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For people
who are people
of color, who deal with
this crap on a daily basis,
loved ones being
murdered and yet they
get up there in
front of the press
and they're so lovely, and
articulate, and understanding,
and compassionate, I just
don't know how they do it.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: So I
want to say one thing about one
part of what you said.
Because there's
a lot there and I
want to unpack one
thing about it.
And that is when you
talked about people
you know who are
less progressive.
And I'm going to say
something really crazy.
And I say lot about
this in the book.
One of my biggest lessons
in the last couple years
has been about my own
biases around people's
political orientation.
And I run now a nonpartisan
women's organization.
It's a women's
political organization,
which I didn't have
time to talk about.
But I established it to be
nonpartisan because I believe
so much that we need more
women in the political process,
whatever their
political affiliation.
And there's actually
a lot of evidence
that when women get
into elected office,
women on both sides of the
aisle, Republican and Democrat,
are actually more
bipartisan, more productive,
are more likely to put the
interests of the country ahead
of their own.
So I had to actually go out.
And I've talked
a lot about this.
I didn't know any
conservative women.
I didn't have any
conservative friends.
I thought I had nothing
in common with them.
And so I went through a
process of seeking out
some Republican women who
were very well respected
in the political world.
And my relationships with
them were life altering,
life altering.
And I see you shaking your head.
I know we don't
agree on everything.
We won't agree on
everything, but the challenge
that we have in the
country today-- now,
if you ask me do I think that
I want to sit down with someone
in the alt-right or with
a white supremacist,
or somebody who is a
virulent anti-semite
and try to have a rational
conversation so that we can
understand each other better?
No.
I will say that.
I have nothing in
common with somebody
who is that hateful about
entire groups of people.
I cannot relate to that, and I
wish I was a better person than
I'd be willing to take that on.
I can't.
But the truth is the vast
majority of Americans
are nowhere near those
polar ends of the scale.
And it is the dystopian
world of the current media
cycle that makes us
think that is the case.
And it means that we're left
likely to have some very
important conversations.
And there are a lot of common
bonds between people who
have different political views.
And if we can't have
those conversations,
if we're so
uncomfortable with them,
it's another piece
of this equation,
that we have to be able to do
that and find common ground
and to respect each other.
And look, I think that
is in some ways happening
in this election.
The Republicans
who have subscribed
to Never-Trump specifically
because of the racism
and the misogyny that has
been such a critical part
of this campaign.
I may not agree with
them on a lot of things,
but I thoroughly agree
with them on that.
So my only point
is that I think we
have to see those conversations
across the political divide
as still part of
the same equation.
It's hard and it's uncomfortable
and we all hate it,
because of the challenge.
I don't like watching Fox News.
It makes me mad because I
don't agree, but I do it.
And I go on the
show and I do it,
because I don't know how I
understand the country if I'm
totally tuning it
out, just as I would
want them, more conservatives,
watching MSNBC, right?
So I mean, these are
some of these big,
hard things that we're
going to have to face,
unless we're OK with
where we are today,
which I think most of
us probably aren't.
So it's in no way
meant as a criticism,
and I think we're
all doing our best
to try to contribute
to a better discourse,
but I had just to say
something about that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
more adding on that.
I thought I'll give you
an easier question there.
I live in Queens, which
is I guess the most
diverse neighborhood now.
ALYSIA REINER: It is.
It's true.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: So I'm lucky on that.
However, when I was growing
up, I grew in India,
where I had my own
feelings about that,
that before the '90s, I would
go into each of the neighbors'
homes, whether they were Hindus
or Muslims, it doesn't matter.
I would go into a mosque
right away without much issue.
Suddenly, I realized
something happened.
Everybody was talking about it.
It was like, '91, '92.
And then we stopped going
to each other's houses
unless they were
the same religion.
We stopped going across
the mosques and temples.
Something happened, and I
realized, "oh, some mosque
was demolished in
'91." [INAUDIBLE]
And that segregation,
to my surprise
when I went back a couple of
years ago, is still there.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So now, actually I
thought somehow in my mind,
"oh, that's temporary.
It will go away."
No, across a generation,
it's still there.
So segregations, when they
happen, they just stay.
That's what my take is, unless
you do something about it.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Right.
It doesn't.
And people ask us all the time.
I get asked all the time.
As someone who
works on this stuff,
I get asked all the time.
Do you think that
the rise of Gen Y,
Gen Y in the United States, as
the most of diverse generation
in history, the most well
educated generation in history,
that's just going
to change things?
I don't know that it
does, automatically.
I actually think
it does take work.
And I'm glad you mentioned
the religious piece.
I wrote a little bit
about that, but that's
another place where we
make choices every day
about the kind of churches that
we go to and whether or not
we're choosing churches and
synagogues or mosques that are
welcoming and inclusive or not.
I think in the Christian
community especially,
there's so many different--
there's 1,000 flavors.
There's that question of
choosing churches that are
more diverse or less diverse.
And it's another way that
we make those choices
for our families and
create conversation or not.
but these are very
closely held beliefs,
and people get
very uncomfortable
when their closely held beliefs
are in anyway challenged,
but that's the
plurality of our nation.
How do we not do that?
I mean, in the film, there's
been so much-- anyway,
what were you doing to say?
ALYSIA REINER: I was
just going to say--
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Sorry,
did you have something else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had
a continued question.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Please.
AUDIENCE: So on that round,
I think with four year olds,
we'd have an easier shot there.
Because they can keep three
things in their mind, right?
If they decide hey, if they
talk to everybody and chat
with everybody, then
that's the best start.
So I have a four year old.
And he asks me sometimes
that he wants to be a girl,
or he wants to be this,
he wants to be that.
I say, "oh yeah.
You can choose.
The world has come to this.
You can be whatever you
want later on, but not now.
Let's figure out
what you want to be."
So if he asked me how is
meeting different people
or different kinds
of people useful,
how is diversity
useful to him, and you
have to say only three things,
because it's a four year old.
They can't remember
more than three.
What would you say?
Why would diversity
be useful to you
growing up or later in life?
ALYSIA REINER: To a four
year old or to a grown up?
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
To a four year old.
You're saying to
a four year old.
I don't know.
What did you say?
AUDIENCE: I'm still thinking.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
You're still looking?
You're still thinking
about the answer.
You do [INAUDIBLE]
four year olds.
What would yours be?
I love that question.
ALYSIA REINER: So if my
four year old asked me--
I just want to be clear.
If my four year old asked me
why I have diversity important?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, or useful
to them growing up.
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah,
useful to them growing up.
AUDIENCE: Why would [INAUDIBLE]
"Crossing the Thinnest Line"
would be useful.
ALYSIA REINER: That
my honest answer,
if she said that right
now-- I'm an actress,
so I have to imagine that
I'm doing it right now.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Would
you like me to play Liz?
ALYSIA REINER: No,
you're too pretty.
No, I would say, "baby,
don't you know"--
no, I wouldn't say that.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE: Do you
need more time to prepare?
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah, I do.
But I would really say
the more experience
we have of life, the more
we know of the more people
and the more experiences,
the more compassion we have,
the more we can serve.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
Yeah, that's a good one.
ALYSIA REINER: And then I
would give a concrete example.
Because that's all--
[MUMBLING]
So what I'm thinking
about right now
is what's the concrete example?
And I would probably get
a book about two kids.
And I'm sure they have this.
Someone's written
this beautiful book
about you walk a
mile in my shoes
and I walk a mile in yours.
And how do we then appreciate
each other's lives?
And it really is what
Lauren was talking
about-- make friends with
that super conservative guy
that you don't understand.
Because if you understand
him, in that process,
he'll understand you.
I was actually
thinking I dare anyone
to come make this with me.
I want to make a little
"Saturday Night Live" sketch
of "befriend your
conservative white male."
Because for me, that's
really hard sometimes.
Because their
opinions are so not
mine and I have my own
unconscious bias about that.
And how do we create
more situations
where we're in
rooms together where
we're understanding and then can
have compassion for each other.
I'll say my little
wrap-up about--
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
We're overtime.
ALYSIA REINER: Sorry,
about what I talk about.
And this is a direct
quote from Effie Brown,
who's an amazing producer.
And she talks about
the three things
you can do to change things
for women are hire, mentor,
and invest.
So hire more women,
invest in women.
And if you can't do
either of those, mentor.
LAUREN LEADER CHIVEE:
So we're out of time.
I don't have all the
answers, and I definitely
didn't write the book because
I had all the answers.
I tried to ask some
questions that I hope
we'll all keep thinking about.
And I would really love for
you to buy the book before you
leave, but I would
especially love
for you to continue
this conversation
through social channels and
with your friends and online.
We need this conversation now
maybe more than ever before,
certainly in our lifetime.
And we need it thoughtfully
and inclusively,
and we need to bring
her best to it.
Because these are some of the
most complicated and difficult
challenges of our time.
And I think it takes all
of us working towards it,
working towards the
solution to make it better.
So thank you so much to Karen
and to everyone at Google.
Thank you for having us.
KAREN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]